listen I know you're here for an absurd
creature and I certainly appreciate that
with fair warning this one is a little
bit rough I'm talking an animal that
lives inside a hippos rectum kind of
rough in Africa there's a leech that
feeds on hippo rectum and not only that
it feeds exclusively on hippo rectums
these ladies and gentlemen are the life
and times of the hippo but leech so
where to begin I guess it's pretty
simple really
hippos have incredibly tough hides so
tough that leeches can't hope to break
through to get blood the hippo butt
leech has no choice but to exploit the
only bit it can so it crawls up the
hippos leg into its anus and anchors
itself in the rectum using suckers on
either side of its body
here's a purely scientific image of I
believe to be a hippo rectum and the bum
leeches in question here it finds some
soft flesh and digs in with its muscular
maneuverable proboscis and it can take
on as much as ten times its weight in
blood while mosquitoes use
anticoagulants to keep your blood
flowing that's not so with leeches
instead they just deploy anticoagulants
internally on account of getting so
packed full of blood if they didn't it
seized up like bricks now if you have
never seen a hippo have a BM you are
missing out it's a wee bit violent
considering the hippo flicks its tail to
spray the dung around you'd think this
would be an attempt to dislodge the
leeches but I'm sad to say that's not
the case has more to do with males
showing each other who's boss by
crapping all over the place undeterred
by this display of bossiness
the leech enjoys itself a nice meal of
hippo rectal blood you'll excuse me I'm
going to go hurl
you